season three is definitely not gonna be
easy for Claire or any of these people
and it's wrapped I'm so glad I got to
tell her story it was really special
supposed to piss you off there's nothing
else I can do
Tyler leaves and you have the gun where
do you think the story goes from there
I'd be surprised if the story isn't
immediate like immediately picks up
where it left off I don't know I'm not
confirming but that's right I feel like
it's going I don't know what clay does
Beck I don't know how he gets out of it
when we were filming it I did not
realize the sirens would sound that
close where do you think Tyler goes from
here I think it would be great to kind
of see Tyler have some to have some
recovery in there and like to see him
find himself and have that that support
group around him honestly I kind of
wanted to see it pick up at the same
moment and like see it kind of fold out
and see what happens it's such a big
scene what did you make of Jessica and
Justin getting back together in the
finale that is a very complicated
question because I as Alicia
it was very upset because I didn't want
her to go back because it kind of is
toxic in a way but then you see the
redemption Justin has and then you can't
judge Jessica for making her own
decisions because she's finally coming
to terms with her sexuality again and
feeling like her body's her own again so
at first everybody I was really angry
but then I realized I was Alicia and I
was judging Jessica how do you think he
feels about just and Justin seemingly
reconciling I think he doesn't really
know yet so I would imagine that he
would be you'd feel a bit heartbroken to
find out do you think that clay is in a
place where he could have another love
interest in season three I imagined the
last thing clay he's gonna want right
now given his past record so far is
a lot of interest but I think maybe he
won't be able to avoid it I don't know
you don't know what to do pregnant I
think that the topic of abortion would
be something that is explored then I
think it very much could be and it would
be interesting to see how they handle it
because from my point of view
Bryce comes from a powerful family and
they have a way of making things
disappear it'd be very interesting yes
new Chloe and Bryce stay together in
season three do you think I think so I
think so for um for a while if they do
kind of break up I think it would be
kind of towards the end okay why because
well now that she's pregnant - I feel
like they both have a sense of like
really wanting this to kind of work out
she was so loyal even though I wanted
her so not to be right and the second
season that I'm like she's probably
gonna do it again the third season it's
frustrating but like I said like I'm
glad that it worked out that way because
it really does show that girls want
something and then they may not be
strong enough to do it and that's just
so realistic
my parents want to see if you might want
them to adopt you
what some of the scenes that I loved
were between clay and Justin a new
friendship that was kind of formed yeah
how is that for you and what do you love
about that friendship I think it's
really I think one of the least explain
my least expected things I one of most
unexpected things would be for clay and
Justin to become family and also you
know I think that Justin and clay both
saved each other in season two although
we saw it to believe that Justin is
still reverting back to old habits but
they needed each other and who would
have thought that those two people would
end up meeting each other in order to I
don't know like even live right I'm sure
they'll be like roommates so in season
three where do you want a few Marcus go
what I would I would see Marcus explore
his relationship with Bryce in season 3
I think he's very influenced by Bryce
and
who knows maybe we'll see that I think
that her knowing that Jessica went
through the same thing kind of it's like
her only it's like literally her only
person that she trusts right now I think
that there's a lot to be addressed with
clay I mean I think like even seeing
therapy at some point or something just
being having someone to talk to and
having clay be able to face you know
these problems that he has I think he
has a lot of issues to work out we see
him go to a behavioral camp during the
season that specifically targets his
anger issues but that doesn't
necessarily mean that those are the only
issues that he's dealing with especially
now after is his assault you know I just
hope that he's happy and figuring things
out and not being too hard on himself
ultimately everyone's always growing and
changing and Alec certainly is and so
hopefully becoming you're transferring
I'm gonna start over what does
redemption for Brice look like I think
there is hope out there for the Brice's
I don't know that our writers will give
Brice any redeeming qualities down the
road but it'll be its thing to find out
a lot of these cases are just you know
people who have lost their way or
haven't been educated on what consent is
or haven't been taught how to respect
women or how to respect human beings in
general so that's something that can
change as we start to have more of these
conversations and influencing people so
there is hope out there just don't know
if there is the Bryson
I was kind of isn't in a season three
her story is something I'm gonna carry
with me and I think also a lot of other
people are gonna carry with them and I
just hope that if anything I can be
there in a small way on social media
would you come back for flashbacks at
all um if I mean if they want me that's
all up to them but kind of hunters
Hannah's gone Hanna's wrap I'm excited
to see clay being a little wiser a
little more grown-up given everything
that he's gone through and just seeing
how he deals with this moving forward in
his life and not having not carrying the
guilt and weight of hand anymore and
just seeing what new challenges await
for him even though aren't involving
Hannah